carrusel de las artes maría carolina
piña
[Música]
un gusto saludarles nuevamente desde
parís en este espacio en donde
exploramos la vibrante actualidad
cultural francesa quédense con nosotros
porque esta semana les hablaremos de
varios homenajes y de artistas que
buscan hacernos más llevadero este
confinamiento
el escritor de los veteranos franceses
move y science one entra al panteón de
los hombres ilustres en carrusel de las
artes les hablaremos de este autor que
vivió los horrores de la guerra en carne
propia y los contó en sus libros
honores también para el carismático ron
paul belmondo a través de 16 de sus
películas disponibles en netflix
francia conmemora el trágico atentado en
el bataclán cinco años de este cruento
ataque en el corazón de esta mítica sala
de conciertos hoy cerrada por la crisis
sanitaria
cómo viven los músicos este nuevo
confinamiento en francia es lo que le
preguntamos a dos conocidos cantantes
franceses david al ide y julián doha
no
en 2020 el panteón nacional en parís
abrió sus puertas para recibir los
restos de móvil lengua el escritor de
los veteranos franceses de la primera
guerra mundial en este conflicto llengua
perdió su mano izquierda pero con la
derecha se dedicó a escribir sus
memorias de la guerra
[Música]
fue la voz en la literatura francesa de
todos los soldados que sufrieron la
primera guerra mundial
los llamados walid los barbudos como la
mayoría de los hombres movéis shenhua
fue enviado a la guerra cuando tenía
apenas 24 años herido en la moza en 1915
comenzó a escribir en el hospital
durante su convalecencia
de esta forma lengua se convirtió en la
pluma de esa generación traumatizada por
el horror de la guerra y el sufrimiento
humano sus cinco relatos sobre la
experiencia en las trincheras fueron
compilados en 1949 bajo el título de
14-2 del 14 obra que cien años después
fue adaptada en una serie de televisión
pero su obra cumbre fue hubble yo novela
que le valió en 1925 el premio con la
máxima distinción de las letras
francesas como bis yonghua integró
también la academia francesa en 1946 el
traslado de sus restos al panteón
nacional el 11 de noviembre de 2020 es
un homenaje a todos los veteranos
franceses según dijo emanuel
ah
noviembre es el mes de jean-paul
belmondo la estrella francesa de 87 años
entra en la galaxia del cine en
streaming la plataforma netflix acaba de
poner a disposición 16 cintas del actor
francés para quienes quieran descubrir o
volver a ver a este galán y villano
ídolo de toda una generación nos lo
cuenta lucía valentín
luego de adquirir las películas de wifi
y de goda el gigante estadounidense del
streaming pone en su catálogo a
jean-paul belmondo el magnífico
[Música]
a partir del mes de noviembre 16 de las
películas más conocidas del legendario
actor francés pueden verse en esta
plataforma
espn a mí
pekerman
es el magnífico el incorregible el
profesional son todos los apodos que
beben se ha ganado durante su larga
carrera en el cine con sus roles
populares comedias y cintas de autor
somos el antiguo boxeador utilizo su
físico particular y su carisma para
convertirse en uno de los actores
preferidos y prolíficos de la historia
del cine francés en las cintas del galán
del mundo no faltaron nunca las peleas
la acción las bombas y persecuciones
es que se come
[Aplausos]
la policía delincuente héroe payaso
seductor las mil vidas del mundo en 16
películas emblemáticas
y recordamos ahora a otro emblema del
cine el director argentino fernando pino
solanas quien falleció recientemente en
parís después de haber sido
diagnosticado con comida solanas fue un
símbolo del cine político y de la
resistencia contra la dictadura con
películas como la hora de los hornos
surf o más recientemente memorias del
saqueo y este año se cumplen cinco años
del sangriento ataque contra el bataclán
esta mítica si la sala de conciertos
parisina no ha podido recuperarse desde
entonces entre el recuerdo de lo
sucedido y la crisis sanitaria actual
nos amplía melissa barra
año tras año a mediados de noviembre
decenas de anónimos dejan flores a la
entrada de la sala de concierto del
bataclán en homenaje a las 130 víctimas
de los atentados de parís del viernes 13
de noviembre de 2015 los que vivieron
este evento traumático tratan hoy en día
de reconstruirse y de mantener vivas en
ellos la música y la cultura
tomás aruba iba en camino al bar lo que
ajeno cuando tuvo lugar el ataque desde
entonces ha decidido dejar su trabajo
como publicista para dedicarse
enteramente a la música compuso un álbum
para las víctimas de los atentados
[Música]
cuando la muerte toca a tu puerta te das
cuenta que ya no puede seguir dejando
los proyectos para más tarde recibí
mensajes de personas que habían
escuchado el álbum ahí sentí que era lo
correcto en mi vida anterior cuando
concluía un negocio no recibía este tipo
de mensajes
un año después de los ataques la sala de
conciertos de el bataclán volvió a abrir
sus puertas el 13 de noviembre de 2016
acogió un conmovedor y catártico
concierto de sting
es maravilloso
ha sido muy conmovedor después de lo
ocurrido aquí
sting nos transmitió mucha energía eso
está bien porque el bataclán así renace
y no morirá nunca derramó gas de mí
cinco años después de los hechos por
causa de re confinamiento
el homenaje a los atentados de parís se
hará a puerta cerrada el bataclán y
todas las otras salas de concierto
mantienen el telón abajo la philharmonía
de parís sin embargo ha decidido dar un
concierto virtual en honor a las
víctimas
[Música]
y como les decíamos el mundo cultural se
ha visto profundamente afectado por este
segundo confinamiento decidido aquí en
francia medida que obligado al cierre
nuevamente de cines museos librerías y
la parálisis total del sector de la
música las salas de conciertos están
clausuradas hasta nuevo aviso y las
giras han tenido que ser postergadas o
simplemente anuladas vamos a hablar de
esta situación con natalia olivares
quien ya se encuentra aquí con nosotros
en el estudio natalia como hacen los
músicos para sobrevivir a estos tiempos
de comida maría carolina y la palabra
hasta nuevo aviso que decía es lo que
más pesa en este momento de silencio
generalizado en un primer momento en un
primer confinamiento los artistas se
adaptaron hicieron conciertos virtuales
eventos especiales en facebook que en
bueno en las redes sociales pero hoy es
diferente ya llevamos ocho meses y los
artistas no saben cuándo van a volver al
escenario y el público tampoco sabe
cuándo volverá a ver un concierto o un
festival
esa pregunta qué haces tú maría carolina
cómo sobrevivir se la hicimos a la vida
de un artista francés que ha postergado
ya dos veces una super gira por toda
francia una actriz marion para tu solo
momento estamos sin poder hacer nada yo
no trabajo solo en esta gira somos un
equipo de 20 personas o más y todos
estamos bloqueados los que pueden
sobrevivir a esto de todos modos están
mal tristes de no estar trabajando yo
estoy triste de no compartir eso tampoco
de no ver al público hago este trabajo
también porque me gusta el contacto con
la gente y pienso que toda esa gente que
quedó sin otra alternativa de trabajo
pues es una pena un año sin trabajar es
duro un año sin trabajar es muchísimo
todo esto me entristece vivimos un
período realmente es el samu freeze
huelva es suficiente hay un tweet es un
período triste la gira se postergó por
un año hasta nuevo aviso pero se mantuvo
la fecha de la salida del álbum que si
todo va bien saldrá de aquí a unas
semanas
nadal y en este periodo pudiste también
ver a otro artista
conocido y tan popular como david al y
de que también tuvo que postergar su
gira
julian de un artista que alcanzó a sacar
su álbum m y desde un teatro mítico pero
vacío y silencioso nos habló de este
silencio cada vez más preocupante para
el contexto actual efectivamente en el
contexto actual efectivamente el mundo
del espectáculo está al borde de la
agonía la cultura que es el pilar que
sostiene a nuestra sociedad se está
desintegrando por falta de respuesta
porque no hay el apoyo suficiente y esto
desde hace muchos años mucho antes de
que llegara la cobija
[Música]
así lo imaginé
nosotros es un tema de su último disco y
alcanzó in extremis a sacar ese rodaje
ese videoclip que es el último de su
álbum y este álbum se llama m que es el
nombre de este disco pero también el
nombre de la abuela y de la madre de
julian ton dos mujeres importantísimas
que vienen de un mundo las dos del mundo
modesto y militante y ambas le
transmitieron esos valores humanistas
ayudando a mí son dos mujeres que
militaron a lo largo de sus vidas mi
madre quien acogió a las mujeres
víctimas de violencia en una asociación
en la ciudad de alex en el sur de
francia donde yo nací en esa misma
ciudad mi abuela que era esposa de
minero
junto con sus compañeros del sindicato
cgt durante muchos años para obtener
derechos para estas mujeres viudas de
mineros como el hijo de dominación comen
y es también un disco a modo de crítica
social
sandisk y el plan pongas
quizá fútbol blues de limón es un disco
lleno de ternura que sin duda habla
mucho más del ser humano y precisamente
de la manera como la sociedad tiene
tendencia a oponer lo social a la
cuestión ecológica siendo que estos dos
ámbitos están ligados es tan profunda e
íntimamente ligados
fundemos antimonio
[Música]
qué
más
el mundo ha cambiado efectivamente como
nos dice julian dog hay muchísimas
gracias na toleró y bares por abrirnos a
hablar del sector musical en tiempos de
kobe y justamente con la canción la
fiebre de julian droga y vamos a
despedir este programa agradeciéndoles
por su amable sintonía hasta la próxima
[Música]
usted
me gustaba completar un par son reales
hombre a ver si se les declara chicas
que la nube se ha ido nos olvida hablar